Barbara Walters interviewed me two years ago...
...and she said, "Is that really your hair?"
Donald Trump is a business tycoon, investor, television personality...
...and now, a candidate for President.
I am officially running for President of the United States.
But when you think of the Donald's many attributes,...
...one thing trumps 'em all: his hair.
Swept back, shrouded in the shadows, or half hidden under a hat,...
...over the years, Trump's hair has bobbed and weaved.
While some believe he's wearing a hairpiece,...
...Trump says his hair is au naturel.
Is it true, because I'm looking at it and I'm close to pulling it.
There is nothing but his own hair.
It's actually my hair.
He even used the ice bucket challenge to prove it was real.
I guess they want to see whether or not it's my real hair.
Through the years, Trump's golden locks have moved around.
But one thing has stayed the same: his enthusiasm for his signature style.
They say, "You wear the worst hairpiece I've ever seen."
"What a horrible wig."
No, I mean it's actually my hair.